تحقيقات ومرفق بيروت لم تثمر بعد واهالي
الضحايا المئتين واربعه عشر لا يزالون
بانتظار ما يبردوا قلوبهم فما هي مشاهدينا
مراحل التحقيق على مدى اكثر من عامين في
الرابع عشر من اغسطس 2020 عين مجلس القضاء
الاعلى قاضي التحقيق العسكري فادي صوان
لقياده التحقيق في انفجار مرفا بيروت بين
منتصف اغسطس وبدايه سبتمبر امر صوان
باعتقال 25 من موظفين الميناء ومسؤولين من
رتب متوسطه الى منخفضه في نوفمبر من العام
نفسه طلب البرلمان بالتحقيق مع اثناء 10
وزيرا حاليا وسابقا لدورهم في الانفجار ثم
حالتهم لمحكمه خاصه لكن وقتها رئيس مجلس
النواب نبيه بري رفض ذلك بعدها بشهر
ابتهامها صوان رئيس الوزراء المؤقت حينها
حسان دياب ووزير الماليه سابق علي حسن
خليل وزيري الاشغال العامه
طبق غازي زعيتر ويوسف فنيانوس بالاهمال
زعيتر وخليل رفعاه دعوى قضائيه امام محكمه
النقض لابعاد صوان عن التحقيق بحجه انه لم
يكن محايده ولا موضوعا واوقف صوان
تحقيقاته بالفعل وقبل ذلك نعود مشاهدينا
الى المشاهد الاولى من التفجير الماساوي
لانفجار مرفق بيروت فن تابع
[موسيقى]
اكمل المسار القضائي في فبراير 2021 امرت
محكمه النقض بابعاد صوان من التحقيقات
واستبدل بالقاضي طارق البيطار رئيس محكمه
جنايات بيروت في يوليو 2021 طلب بيطار من
البرلمان رفع الحصانه عن النواب والوزراء
السابقين خليل وزعيتر ووزير الداخليه
السابق نهاد المشنوق لكنه لم يلقى استجابه
وطلب بطار الاذن باستجواب رئيسيه امن
الدوله والامن العام واجهت طلباته طبعا
الرفض والتجاهل في الثامن والعشرين من
يوليو 2000 21 رفعت نقابتاه المحامين في
كل من بيروت وترابلس الحسانات عن زعيتر
وخليل وفنيانوس لكنهم ظلوا يتمتعون
نيابيه القاضي البيطار تجاهل 40 دعوه
طالبت بتنحيه واستئناف عمله بعد توقف دام
ثلاثه عشر شهرا
[موسيقى]